hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest bull masters 2020 sorry about no
videos yesterday I was kind of
preoccupied with everything that's been
going on with the park has being taken
down and everything but now it's back up
everything is you know working properly
the the warning on my channel has been
removed and I just want to thank
everyone for for making so much noise on
on the other platforms on Twitter on
reddit and everything it seems that it
got to YouTube and they've reinstated
the video so you are welcome to check it
out if you still haven't I will put the
link in the description below now
getting back to this game it's a it's a
really wild game at the features to move
that could be described as a move of
Legends higher as the title suggests now
that is kind of a bold statement but I
do feel that this move justifies it
however you are here to to see if it
does so without further ado let's check
it out it's Vladislav artemiev also
known as chuck norris versus jana pony
she and let's check it out so our team
we have opens with b3 he goes for the
names ol arson attack and we have 'if i
buy an apple Bishop to b2 going after
the pawn and I'll just knife the c6
defending the pawn we have III and
Knight to f6
we have Bishop to b5 now are going after
the night here and Bishop to d6 now for
the moment blocking at the D pawn but
you need it so so you don't lose the e5
pawn we have Knights to a3 with ideas of
night c4 going after the leadership and
now nice to a five guarding the c-4
square so push it back to e2 this is
actually all standard theory and a6 now
regarding the b v square we have c4 and
here c5 by nipple Knight back to C to
the knife from c2 will will be helpful
in in order for whites to execute to d4
we have Knight back the c6 and now there
is one game in the database for Knight
to f3 was played but here we have d4 and
it is already as of mu9 that we have a
completely new game so we have a capture
fast in the center we have C captures on
before we've eek a person d4 n now
tonight characters on d4 we have Knight
captures and now first Bishop to b4 with
check as you don't have anything to
block the check with we have King to f1
so an April ruins artemiev castling
privileges however in the future you can
go some like g3 King G to then develop
the night bring drugs into the game and
hopefully Castle artificially well only
now he recaptures eek a person d4 and
Queen captures angry for a mountain mo
castles to safety and here it seems like
the the critical continuation for white
is g4 and it's it's a very bold move to
make as you open up your King still it's
an f1 but you are threatening g5 you
want to dislodge the knight and deliver
checkmate on g7 so let's say d5 as you
want to open up some lines the the White
King is still in the center of the board
let's say g5 Knight go somewhere you
cannot go to h5 because just captures
and then checkmate so you have to go to
e8 the guard the g7 pawn but now h4
everything is nicely defended and the
game continues and it's a very very very
interesting position however our team
chooses a more timid line with Bishop to
f3 I just put this Bishop on this
diagonal seems very nice and now b5
napal says ok your king is still on f1 I
want to open up some lines even at the
price of a pawn so artemyev captures but
should capture some d5 you still cannot
recapture because you don't want to get
to checkmate it here on g7 so we have
Queen to c7 by nipple and now with
Quintus e7 you have some ideas of
bringing the rook to e8 could be very
interesting the bishop can now come to
c5 put pressure on the Queen and you
have to be very careful with white so
here we have Knight to e2 and just rook
to e8 so nipple has to figure out how to
get his King to safety while not losing
the game
we have Bishop back to f3 now adding a
defender to the knight and the bishop to
f5 now here never is preparing to bring
the other work to dat and for the price
of one pawn his forces are now fully
fully mobilized and the problem is there
is no good way to Castle artificially
here for example if g3 you still cannot
go here because the bishop h3 check and
now you either go to g1 and you've lost
again castling privileges or you block
with the bishop and then is just
captures captures and you lose the night
on e 2 so that also doesn't work
so what you could do here after Bishop
day five is what never did he is what
Artemyev did he played a Queen to f4
which comes with an attack on the bishop
you get to the Queen out of harm's way
as it's no longer on the D file and you
offer a queen trade you're up a pawn so
why not offer a queen trade and the nape
of course declines Queen to d7 he wants
to keep the pressure going in defense
the bishop gets the Queen out of harm's
way
however this allows art image to go for
Bishop characters on f6 which he does
and this opens up nipples King so G
captures on f6 and now we've reached the
the moment where the magic happens here
again crucial is g4 after g4 you've
given your King an escape square you can
again play Knight the g3 you can then
bring the rook into the game well not
there obviously like like the d1 and
everything is fine for white it's
actually white who is attacking here but
artemyev again went for Knight to g3 he
simply doesn't want to play this g4 move
and now there's a problem now as the as
the quote above the board states if
there would be one player in this event
who could who'd find this move it would
be on so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find it this move of
legends while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
proving Magnus wrong as well if you've
also found it then congratulations and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's the only move that wins
the game it's Bishop to b1 and that's
just that black has no moves and now
what's what's so special about Bishop to
b1 is that you're already threatening
rook to e1 checkmate as the Bishop
covers d1 square and it's incredibly
difficult to defend this for example if
you play anything that doesn't help you
you just get checkmated if you capture
the bishop then Queen the d3 check
that's kind of the point of Bishop to be
one you want to force the rook here and
now after this check you will again get
to checkmate it let's say Queen captures
here with trick you have to block and
now of course the the beautiful finisher
Queen captures on f1 King has the
capture and the rook to e1 is again
checkmate so this is just
one amazing position how how Bishop the
b1 wins in all of the lines you could go
Quinta c1 kind of attack the bishop once
again Guardi one square but here you
just give up the queen a rookie one
check you have to give up the queen and
it's not much better here you're again
completely lost
so here our team have actually found a
way to defend and keep the material
balance but only for a little while here
he played King to g1 and it's actually
an interesting defense because after
looked to e1 check what what he played
nice the f1 blocking and now Queen to d3
now just threatening Queen captures here
with checkmate here
artemiy found Queen to g4 check King to
88 and now Bishop to e2 now giving up
the bishop however then you can pick up
this Bishop so here we have route
capture sandy - but now rook captures on
b1 and now of course if Napo captures
then Artemis captures the rookin eat you
but nepo says I'm not interested in that
Bishop to c5 and that there is no
defense against capture on f2 you cannot
push the pawn as its pinned Bishop
captures and f2 is the threat of
checkmate so there's that our team have
tried h4 to give the King some breathing
room but it doesn't help
just rook captures on f2 and there is
nothing more to be done here rook to e1
was played but now nipple just played
rook to f4 attack the Queen opened up a
discovery here and and the next move you
lose the Queen and you also get
checkmated so it was in this position
unmoved 27 that Vladislav Artemyev
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once you move the
King the Queen gets captured and you are
you are again getting checkmated with
with nothing else to do here so really
an impressive game I wanted to show it
right away as soon as it happened
because I was I was incredibly impressed
with the move and well then all of this
kind of happened and I didn't I didn't
get the time but I said that this is
definitely the next game we're going to
show and yeah it's just amazing stuff
how how that g4 idea was always
somewhere for white and if he had gone
for g4 instead of this immediate night
g3 he gives his King some breathing room
the rook
into the game everything is fine but
with this we are going to show it I
don't do this very often but when I do
you know it's it's a good move we are
going to see the move again in slow
motion so let's let's check it out
so Bishop to b1 and it's all over that's
just it so really really an impressive
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Alexander Claude Pinto as
Simon Gibson as sindelle kumara Braden
let's go it's and pull down for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
chess table Masters 20/20 checking up
and your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you guys are interested I will be
streaming some old games on my other
channel so if you want to check it out I
will put a link to that channel in the
description as well I don't use it very
often but if you guys are interested in
that I might be doing something there as
well so thank you all and I will see you
soon